i knew netflix's latest cringe-inducing
reality show the ultimatum was going to
be great when i heard it holds the
guinness book of records for mentioning
boners
i touched the boner as well i didn't
know there were boners involved i got a
boner so obviously i was interested and
had to take a deep dive into love
because nothing says i love you then
issuing your partner an ultimatum is
this
like an ultimatum come join me in this
beautiful disaster of a show as we
answer the question is love blind oh
wrong show the premise of the ultimatum
is pretty simple get married or break up
with six couples all of whom being in
relationships of at least a year and a
half or longer with one person in each
couple wanting to get married and the
other holding out this is where the
ultimatum comes in i basically told
hunter we either get engaged or
we break up let's meet our totally not
unhinged or emotionally traumatized
couples shall we first is alexis and
hunter if hunter wasn't making enough
money that was reasonable i would walk
away
hunter is not perfect for husband
material yet because i make more than
him what are you looking to get out of
your
potential partner finances are like so
important to solidify marriage for me is
a financial decision because nothing
says love more than money this is alexis
and she's the one issuing the ultimatum
to hunter who isn't ready to commit just
yet right hunter i'm not ready to
propose to alexis at this moment but if
i met the perfect person
i
would be ready to be engaged tomorrow
second we have madeline and colby with
colby being the one to issue the
ultimatum i am worth her
whole heart and if she can't
see that
i need to find somebody else who can
don't let his sweet talking get to you
this man is a piece of work i don't
think houdini reveals his tricks and
that's what you [ __ ] just did
madeleine on the other hand wins the
award for most drunk i mean she's got it
pretty together when compared to some of
the others on shows like love is blind
hey my name is fred and i love him and
i'm so lucky
i'm gonna go watch your dude
you and your dude and i know you
i know you baby i know you
if you were to ever to actively go after
my husband
we then have april and jake my name is
april i'm a psycho [ __ ]
and
if there's anything i need to find out i
will find out she's given an ultimatum
to jake who has different priorities i
want to travel i want to have fun
because everyone knows you can't do that
with a wife next is rey and zay i stay
in the gym i have a degree i cook i
clean and i know how to [ __ ] she's given
the ultimatum to zay who doesn't want to
rush anything i'm ready to get [ __ ] up
and just forget all this even happened
me too zay up next is lauren and nate
with nate totally unsure of what this
show is all about i was anticipating
like seeing crew of all these guys you
just want to [ __ ] my girlfriend
what the [ __ ] which is of course why he
was the one to issue the ultimatum to
lauren and want to be on the show i'm
ready to drink it's the only way i was
able to get through this show lauren and
rounding at the couples are randall and
shanique whose chemistry is about as dry
as my vagina it's here in the romantic
city of austin texas that the couples
will split up and have one week to
establish new connections with the other
contestants and just like my dating
experience the process can be downright
painful with some of the contestants
totally vibing while others you have a
wild side
horse out of a wild sock i like sci-fi
books yeah
what made you attracted to me your voice
for some reason like your voice is like
really raspy
[Laughter]
i like that laugh
after a week of casual dates and
one-on-ones the contestants have to
choose someone who isn't their initial
partner to go on a three-week
accelerated trial marriage where they'll
move in together meet each other's
families and experience what life is
like with a totally insane person and
this choosing ceremony or whatever the
hell they call it is absolutely
hilarious nick here wants to choose
madeline and just look at her reaction
it's it's kind of like in elementary
school when the teacher mentions you're
going to be doing a group project and
you have to quickly whisper to your
friend to team up before you get matched
with that weird kid who snorts his own
dandruff speaking of nate man did they
do this dude dirty during this wild
ceremony he ends up proposing to lauren
saying that he's willing to forgo having
children if it means he gets to spend
the rest of his life with her you gotta
give madeline the award for best
reactions just take a look at her here
colby is a big [ __ ] disturber and i'm
here for it calling out nate's
spontaneous proposal to lauren as fake
and disingenuous after all just a few
minutes earlier nate told madeline he
was going to choose her you told me 10
minutes before proposing that you were
going to choose me and then april chimes
in with this absolute gem about nate
when we were having our conversations
that like instead of your eyes here like
you were looking at my tits dude what so
it's probably a good thing that lauren
accepts nate's proposal because i don't
think that man was going home with
anyone else hunter also proposes to
alexis and by episode 3 this show has a
better track record than almost every
other reality tv program but it's april
who calls these proposals out arguing
that the whole purpose of this
experience is to find out more about
yourself and your relationship so that
you can grow and work through the
problems that brought about these
ultimatums in the first place alexis
hunter nate and lauren haven't even got
past the first stage of this experience
so it's reasonable for her to question
the genuineness of these proposals but
if you want me to be real i don't think
that engagement was real and i would be
oh my god are you [ __ ] kidding me
phase one ends and so begins the
three-week trial marriages with our new
couples ray and jake shanique and zay
colby and april and randall and madeline
will our couples find new love or will
it strengthen their relationship with
who they came here with jake and ray
immediately hit it off and i would argue
they're the strongest new couple of the
bunch they go to meet rey's dad a race
car driver because nothing says love
than getting into a cramped car with
your potential father-in-law the last
guy her dad took around the track [ __ ]
himself but the most hilarious dynamic
is that of madeleine and her friends who
really don't see colby as a good fit for
her one of the friends even slept with
colby calling the experience unmemorable
in college colby and i didn't end up
hooking up
wasn't really something rememberable
i am never going to financially recover
from this so when randall comes into the
picture that girls are immediately
smitten the parents also drop some great
pearls of wisdom like shanique's mom who
says you shouldn't have to
put him an ultimatum like marry me or
else you should know your worth or
jake's friend so you're sexually
attracted to
him as the weeks press on the sexual
tension between the couples grow as they
explore their boundaries this culminates
in a girls and guys night out where they
get completely wasted and divulge their
sexual frustrations with one
another how did you know that he bonered
i don't think i've ever heard boner used
as a verb was i flattered
yes i was hey we had our kisses too
before we gonna hear my mind what's
going on on the lips
are you okay
i'm fine i just uh
threw up in my mouth a little bit april
here uses the opportunity to vent the
girls her frustration about jake he
doesn't want to get married yet has
unprotected sex with her all the time
what's the disconnect every [ __ ] time
we've never used production he's never
pulled down on me right and like to have
infertility shooting you say you're not
ready to have kids but you're actually
meanwhile aside from a bit of beat
between colby and zay that guys are
having genuine conversations about their
feelings i think that's what shanique
has has really taught me to it's okay
not to be okay okay that's boring back
to the girls look at us at this table
you think there's not boners all around
brandon's sexy he kissed me i touched it
on her as well all in all the girl and
guy night catch-ups were a great way to
make all our couples jealous of one
another and totally have no ill effect
on any of their mental well-being as our
trial marriages come to an end and
sexual tensions rise one of the new
couples goes all the way zay and
shanique a little fact zay will keep
secret when he's reunited with rey colby
says this gym of a line about april and
madeleine once again nails her reaction
she grew into a woman during our time
together
did she start her period or did she lose
her virginity with the trial marriage is
over the final phase begins with our
original couples getting back together
to see if anything has changed and of
course like any sane person would do
some of the contestants decide to go
through their partner's phones i was in
colby's bathroom
and you know
happened to flip through his apple watch
oh yeah i just happened to flip through
it seems as though colby has been
hooking up with someone else and you're
not gonna believe his reasoning for
doing so i did it for madeline i did it
because madeline asked of these things
you heard that right he hooked up with
someone else because he thought
madeleine wanted that of him basically
he argues that he wasn't getting that
type of connection with april and
therefore he wasn't getting the full
ultimatum experience he was supposed to
be getting so he went out and sought
another person to establish a connection
with aka [ __ ] and madeleine couldn't get
mad at him because that's what he was on
the show to do this is a mastery level
of gaslighting [ __ ] april also goes
through jake's phone who left it
unlocked when he passed out in bed not
only did she take a look at his photos
some of which showed ray twerking at the
club she airdropped them to herself and
i am psycho and i air drop them to
myself now they actually show this video
in the reunion special but look at this
woman underneath here computer enhance
is that madeline speaking of which
madeline decides to invite colby out for
drinks with her friends oh man how's
y'all's nights going so far so good
sorry about walking at a bad time or
what this date quickly descends into
madness and the best part of it are the
reactions from madeleine's friends how
about hold off the tequila a little bit
and then maybe we can have a discussion
when have i blamed you
hey remember alexis who got engaged at
the beginning of the show she's having
her bachelorette party and april shows
up saying her period's 12 days late
every [ __ ] time we've never used
production she's never pulled down on me
alexis basically calls april out saying
she hasn't established a connection with
colby so she's not really getting that
experience of what it's like to be with
someone else but nobody else has been in
a relationship here with jake for two
years except for me and april ends up
storming off congratulations again on
your engagement
hi [ __ ]
[Laughter]
by episode 7 it looks like things are
really going well for our couples i
don't want to leave here engaged i just
i think it'd be a huge mistake i just
don't think that
i need to be
engaged right now in a complete role
reversal zay tells rey he's ready to be
engaged but now it's rey the one who
initiated the ultimatum who says she has
to work out her own [ __ ] before she's
ready this causes zay to storm out turn
off his phone and not come home until 8
am the next morning so obviously rey
thinks he's [ __ ] around and this is
one of zay's biggest red flags every
time he's confronted with something that
could hurt him emotionally instead of
talking it through he walks away this
even happens in the reunion show where
he just gets up and leaves he says this
is because of trauma he experienced as a
child and when shanique calls him out on
this guess what he does he walks away
again it's shanique who actually puts it
best and i'm paraphrasing here but there
comes a time when you need to face your
own problems and when people call him
out on it it doesn't mean they're
belittling his trauma unfortunately for
zay and rey they split up before our
final episode but rey still has a thing
for jake and this leads us into our
final episode where the couples need to
decide if they're going to stay or walk
away and what better location to have
this in than in an outdoor shed by an
abandoned parking lot up first is
randall and shanique randall says this
experience has taught him that she's the
one and he
proposes will you marry me
yes april and jake have their talk
outside a stinky barn he tells her he
can't go through with an engagement and
the two split however jake takes a quick
jaunt into the nearby forest to ask out
rey offering her a vacation to anywhere
in the world and finally madeleine and
colby i was like there is no way these
two are getting hitched especially
considering it was madeline who didn't
want to going into this and who also
seems to have the most doubts but guess
what this show is an absolute train
wreck and not only does he propose they
get married right there on the spot and
boy does colby make quick work because
on the reunion show madeline is seven
months pregnant and um colby's the daddy
absolutely yeah
the show even gets the baby a cute
silver goblet because it's gonna need it
with these two being their parents the
reunion special isn't too crazy but we
do get to see where all the couples are
right now alexis and hunter are still
engaged same with nate and lauren
shanique and randall split and rey went
back to zay to try to work things out
leaving jake and is now in a
relationship with a woman so all in all
does the ultimatum work i'm ready to get
[ __ ] up and just forget all this even
happened thanks for watching everyone be
sure to like and subscribe and leave
your thoughts about the show below i
also have tons of other reality tv
videos in my playlist above you can also
follow me on twitter and instagram at
think story yt until next time remember
owner owner
as well didn't know there were boners
involved